Republican senator Lindsey Graham has
occasionally been one of the strongest
and most unhinged Defenders of President
Donald Trump in the past sometimes
screaming sometimes crying and becoming
indignant sometimes saying you've just
got to send Trump money and maybe me as
well will Lindsey Graham appeared
yesterday on ABC's This Week With George
Stephanopoulos and it is an absolute
Delight to see but also disturbing
because we know many of the Maga people
are going to buy these arguments on
multiple occasions George Stephanopoulos
attempted to get Lindsey Graham to
answer really simple questions about
Trump and Lindsey Graham went all but
her emails quite literally talking about
Hillary Clinton let's look at the first
clip here is a very simple question do
you stand by Trump did nothing wrong
Donald Trump has said repeatedly
repeatedly that he did nothing wrong do
you believe that
well here's what I believe we live in an
America where if you're the Democratic
candidate for president Hillary Clinton
Secretary of State you can set up a
private server in your basement to
conduct government business and when an
investigation has had a bachelor
activity no let me finish oh that was
ridiculous well yeah I'm trying to
answer the question from a republican
point of view that may not be acceptable
on this show well it's not an answer
right
do you see it do you agree Trump did
nothing wrong
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton wait I'd like you to answer the
I am answering the question from a
republican point of view whoa okay okay
uh George Stephanopoulos tried again and
said there are audio recordings here
there are audio recordings and Lindsay
figures out a way again to talk about
Hillary Clinton there is an audio tape
of Donald Trump saying he knows this is
secret information he knows he's sharing
with other people how is that okay
it's I'm not saying it's okay I'm not
saying it's okay to take a hammer to uh
a Blackberry I don't think I think none
of this is okay
so then referring again to Hillary
Clinton uh you know acid washing hard
drives and taking hammers to
blackberries or whatever it was she was
accused of so a couple different things
here first of all it is not a defend I'm
going to deal with the Hillary Clinton
allegation specifically even though I
know it's like we're a decade late on
the whole thing and he's still talking
about it but give me a moment to lay
this all out
it is not a defense to say
because other prosecutors in other
matters at other times made different
charging decisions after other
investigations related to other possible
charges
that has nothing to do with Trump and
it's sort of like if I was arrested for
whatever right if I would if I was
arrested for attempted murder and then I
say someone else 10 years ago in a
different state was investigated under
different circumstances for attempted
murder and they weren't charged that
doesn't mean anything that's not any
it's not actually a defense
second part of this Hillary Clinton was
accused of being extremely careless in
her handling of classified information
she was not accused of intentionally
disclosing information there is no
evidence she lied to investigators she
cooperated and handed over tens of
thousands of emails etc etc
Trump is accused of willfully risking
National Security secrets and conspiring
with lawyers and others to conceal
documents and make false statements he
did not cooperate with the investigation
he hid the documents for months at his
house in boxes near his toilet Hillary
Clinton was cleared twice by the FBI of
criminal charges so the situations
aren't actually analogous but it doesn't
matter to people like Lindsey Graham one
of our sponsors is yada the Free banking
app that makes it fun to save money just
like a regular bank account you can
withdraw your money anytime and it's
fully FDIC insured when you keep your
money in a yada bank account you'll have
a shot at winning nightly cash prizes
ranging from two cents to a million
dollars for every twenty five dollars in
your account you get one recurring
ticket to the nightly prize drawing so
if you deposit a hundred dollars you get
four tickets every single night without
needing to make any more deposits yada
also offers some great budgeting
features the possibility of early
paydays a debit card that rewards you
with up to one hundred percent cash back
and tickets on every purchase yata
members have already won over 15 million
dollars so say goodbye to the
traditional savings account with the
minimal interest rate free economics
have described prize linked savings
accounts like a no lose Lottery download
the app now start saving for a chance to
win big with yada the app where savings
meets excitement go to with yada.com
Pacman the link is in the description